bienvenue dans vue de Russie le magazine
hebdomadaire qui analyse la propagande
de Vladimir Poutine sur fond de guerre
en Ukraine avec Elena wolochine bonsoir
Elena bonsoir Stéphanie cette semaine
vous faites une revue en musique pour
nous parler des efforts de la propagande
en russe pour mobiliser la jeunesse
autour de l'opération militaire spéciale
en Ukraine comme l'appelle Vladimir
Poutine oui et on en parle parce que
cette semaine un clip fait le buzz en
Russie celui du chanteur chaman la
chanson s'appelle oui traduisez nous ce
clip a été tourné sur la Place Rouge
regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce clip fait débat Elena parce que cette
mise en scène et ce look le look du
chanteur rappelle selon certains
internautes l'esthétique nazi oui c'est
ce que relève la blogosphère russe qui
compare cette chanson à un épisode du
film cabaret ce film dans lequel a
notamment tourné la Isa Minnelli qui
date de 1972 et la scène en question des
pins l'essor du mouvement nazi dans le
Berlin du début des années 30 regardez
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'il y a certaines
ressemblances dans le look et les
paroles oui une ressemblance qui suscite
la polémique pas seulement chez les
anti-puttines mais aussi chez les
soutiens du régime qui trouvent que
chaman ressemble un petit peu trop à un
membre des Jeunesses hitlériennes dans
cette vidéo son clip en plus est sorti
le 20 avril date de l'anniversaire de
Adolf Hitler écoutez ce qu'on dit par
exemple Michael Nike qui est un
journaliste et blogueur Russo américain
qui compte un million 600 000 abonnés
sur YouTube
tout le monde a déjà relevé l'adoption
par le régime russe du style esthétique
de l'Allemagne nazie depuis Medvedev qui
défie dans les usines portant un
par-dessus cuir jusqu'au discours de
Vladimir Poutine qui raconte qu'on nous
a attaqué que nous défendons nos
territoires historiques même son
discours avant l'invasion en 2022 était
identique à ceux de Hitler avant
l'invasion de la Pologne c'est parallèle
on les connaît déjà mais en ce moment
nous assistons à une évolution lorsqu'on
sein même de cette société russe loyale
à l'invasion et au pouvoir les gens sont
comme les nazis dans ce même Hans
sommes-nous des méchants pourquoi a-t-on
des têtes de mort sur nos képis et
toutes ces discussions parmi les turbos
patriotes c'est grâce au clip de chaman
c'est pourquoi on peut lui dire merci
blogueur les appelle sont inquiets de
cette ressemblance qui est ce chaman
est-ce une star en Russie alors shaman
de son vrai nom yaroslave dronov c'est
un ancien participant de l'équivalent
russe de l'émission The Voice et le
début de la guerre à grande échelle en
Ukraine il a été récupéré par la
propagande russe pour séduire la
jeunesse et faire l'apologie de la
guerre de Vladimir Poutine on le voit
sans arrêt sur les chaînes de télévision
son niveau de popularité réelle il est
aussi difficile à estimer que le niveau
réel du soutien des Russes à l'opération
spéciale de Vladimir Poutine mais chaman
est de tous les concerts on le voit en
ce moment à l'écran au stade Louis quai
il est de toutes les tournées
patriotiques y compris dans les
territoires
occupés en Ukraine où il se vante de
rendre visite de mobiliser sur le front
regardé par exemple cette séquence qu'il
affirme avoir tourné dans la région de
Kerson en Ukraine
[Musique]
sauf qu'avec Vladimir Poutine qui
prétend lutter contre le nazisme la
dernière production de ce chanteur Elena
ne sert pas vraiment la cause non c'est
ce qui s'appelle un raté à l'heure où
l'État russe multiplient les efforts
pour enrôler la jeunesse pas sûr
cependant que vu le niveau
d'endoctrinement déjà atteint les Russes
lisent l'histoire à l'esthétique de la
même façon témoin se forum qui s'est
tenu hier à Volgograd l'ancienne
Stalingrad il était dédié à
l'anniversaire des 80 ans de la victoire
des Soviétiques dans cette bataille il a
rassemblé plus de 300 enseignants venus
de toute la Russie et sans surprise il a
opéré comme le fait sans cesse Vladimir
Poutine un parallèle entre hier et
aujourd'hui entre les héros de ce que
les Russes appellent la grande guerre
patriotique et ceux qui combattent
aujourd'hui en Ukraine écouter un
extrait du discours d'ouverture de ce
forum
il y a 80 ans les héros de Stalingrad
ont surmonté les fascistes par leur
professionnalisme leur sens du sacrifice
leur courage leur bravoure et leur
mérites il faut suivre leur exemples et
leur enseignement tout comme il faut
prendre exemple sur la génération
actuelle des héros nos militaires et nos
bénévoles qui défendent la population
civile du Dombas et combattent pour le
droit de la Russie à rester un État
souverain
et donc un forum intitulé école des
héros destinés à expliquer aux jeunes
Russes comment devenir un héros dans la
Russie de Vladimir Poutine oui elle a
réponse elle est simple sans rouler dans
l'armée et éventuellement être prêt à
aller mourir dans une guerre qui vous
l'avez entendu serait celle pour la
défense de la patrie une histoire
toujours écrite à l'envers en Russie et
les manuels d'histoire d'ailleurs sont
réécrits un chapitre dédié à l'opération
spéciale devrait apparaître dans les
nouveaux manuels scolaires édités pour
la prochaine rentrée scolaire de
septembre elle glorifiera sans doute il
le référra sans doute ce chapitre les
exploits de ces héros c'est ce qu'a
annoncé en tout cas hier le ministre
part dans il annonçait auparavant mais
hier il a lancé une annonce aux
participants de ce forum lors de
l'ouverture je vous propose donc
d'écouter Sergueï kraft soft le ministre
russe de l'éducation
nous élevons nos enfants par l'exemple
de ceux qui servaient leur patrie de
façon désintéressée cela motive les
élèves il tente vers les idéaux du bien
de la justice et de la morale
peuvent-ils s'enrouler et bien il
rejoignent par exemple les rangs de la
Youn Armia littéralement la jeune armée
une organisation de jeunesse dont
l'esthétique aussi selon les
observateurs de la région et quelque
part à mi-chemin entre les consomal
Soviétiques et les jeunesse hitlériennes
cette armée est le recrute à partir de
l'âge de 8 ans et comme nous faisons une
édition en musique Stéphanie regardez
leurs clips de présentation
[Musique]
alors la chanson qui accompagne ce clip
que vous avez entendu elle a été écrite
en 2000 à la demande de Vladimir Poutine
et en 2016 au moment de la création de
la Youn Armia elle a été adoptée comme
l'hymne officiel de l'organisation cette
organisation elle compte aujourd'hui un
million 300000 enfants et adolescents à
travers toute la Russie et certains de
ces membres meurent déjà sur le front de
la guerre en Ukraine regardez cette
autre épisode survenu hier lors de ce
forum de Volgograd les élèves d'une
école de Sébastopol en Crimée annexée
rendent hommage à leur éducateur en
charge de leur éducation patriotique il
est mort en Ukraine en septembre dernier
regardez
par une chaude journée scolaire de
septembre une nouvelle tragique à
secouer notre école de village Alexandre
chéremianov est mort à l'opération
militaire spéciale
nous les enfants dont il a utilisé les
coeurs par l'amour sincère de la patrie
de son histoire et de ses gens nous
sommes restés
un vrai patriote de notre patrie
je pense que nous pouvons le constater
d'après son exploit
par son exemple il nous a montré comment
il fallait aimer son pays
ce processus éduquer les enfants d'après
les noms et les exploits de nos héros
c'est très important par les temps qui
courent merci beaucoup à vous
le message est clair si vous êtes un
vrai patriote et que vous voulez servir
la Russie vous devez faire comme ceux
qui vont mourir en Ukraine oui c'est le
message que reçoivent aujourd'hui les
écoliers russes pas seulement dans les
écoles mais à travers les multiples
programmes d'éducation patriotique mise
en place par le gouvernement ces
programmes il nous date pas de 2022 ils
se sont multipliés déjà à partir de 2014
depuis le début en fait de l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par la Russie là où avant la
Russie était célèbre pour son
enseignement du sport et de la musique
aujourd'hui les classes les plus
religieuse pour les parents sont
considérés comme celles des cadets ces
classes militaires dans les écoles quand
au sport et à la musique ils sont
grandement mis à contribution pour
soutenir l'effort de guerre de Vladimir
Poutine en Ukraine merci Elena wolochine
vue de Russie on vous retrouve la
semaine prochaine même heure 18h40
vendredi
la guerre en Ukraine